[Music]
welcome to the program the battle for
control of afghanistan's panshir valley
is showing no sign of easing with
taliban and resistance fighters both
claiming they have the upper hand the
region walled off by mountains north of
kabul is the last to hold out against
taliban rule there are reports of more
fierce fighting between the national
resistance front made up of militias and
former afghan security force members and
taliban forces
both sides claim they've inflicted heavy
losses on each other a top u.s general
has warned the conflict could lead to
civil war
let's get the very latest now from
charles stratford who's in kabul on this
and we do start with that update that we
need on the situation the panshir valley
a very um
fluid situation at the moment between
the two sides
that's right so yes claims and counter
claims
by the two sides we understand there's
been heavy fighting in the last 24 hours
we spoke to people who were inside the
valley yesterday they said um that uh
yeah there'd been a lot of shelling a
lot of panic
um the taliban
desperate to basically try and keep
seemingly people away as well um
the security situation they're seemingly
deteriorating massive concerns for what
is understood to be between 150
to 200 000 people in the valley mainly
ethnic tajiks
um we understand according to an italian
medical organization that they have been
treating casualties inside the valley as
well the taliban say or had said this
morning that they'd taken control of
four of the seven districts
um that is being refuted by uh the
limited information that we're getting
out of the panshir valley the nrf saying
they're putting up stiff resistance
we're getting reports
that they retook a town called anaba
uh sorry a district called anaba which
is on the southern end of the valley um
they said that um they're reporting that
they blew up a bridge to try and halt a
taliban advance
we know that the taliban are certainly
according to them have surrounded the
valley we also know that the nrf have
got a lot of weapons in there when we
were at the entrance or close to the
entrance a couple of days ago speaking
to villagers just outside the valley
they said that um around the time or
just before the taliban took control
of kabul there was a big effort
seemingly by the nrf to get as many
weapons as they could into the valley um
they say that they've been preparing for
this sort of fight for a long time for
years so it's expected it's believed
there are serious amounts of weapons in
there but of course they are hugely
outnumbered
um the taliban are
obviously very strong and as i say they
have surrounded the the the valley it's
important to say though that this isn't
just one valley this is an area with a
with a number of different valleys in it
um and as we know it has been incredibly
difficult um for firstly the soviets in
the 1980s they never took control of it
nor the taliban
and this has massive ramifications not
only for obviously the huge concerns for
the vast civilian population in the area
but also the politics of this country
the taliban have been saying for the
last well more than a week now that uh
they're at the point of
announcing the formation of a new
government a government that they say is
going to be inclusive of all ethnic
minorities well the tajiks represent
about a quarter of the population of
this country so some analysts are saying
that um they say it's inconceivable that
the taliban could come out and announce
a new inclusive government with this
ongoing conflict
with that tajik area the panshire valley
so yeah there are huge questions about
the safety of thousands of people
and the political stability of the
country in general